land und brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten morgen guten augen markus
wo erreiche ich dich wieder zurück in
der kemenate dass das wort kemenate
gerade so die runde machten bekannt
aber was ist deine kemenate ist quasi so
ein studierzimmer quasi nur flächen ja
wir stellen also da sind
weit über 1000 bücher drin und ansonsten
den kleiderschrank und das fungiert auch
noch als gästezimmer wobei es ein
bisschen bedrückend ist darin zu
schlafen weil auf der einen seite sind
diese riesigen regale wo man über denkt
wie trägt der boden gas auf der anderen
seite der schrank also dass es schon
schon 1001 gesenkt es ist richtig
gesicht hast du das team das nach reger
eingezogen extra jetzt umgehen
versteuert das war also das war ein
ehemaliges gewerbegebäude okay und
deswegen ist das auch vom von belastbar
ich weiß das ja weil ich auch so ein
schweres aquarium hatte
eine tonne wie du hast ne kreis wusste
ich gar nicht du hast ja wie helmut kohl
sein aquarium ja genau also es ist
wahrscheinlich eine der vielen dinge die
mich und helmut kohl verbinden ist das
aquarium
ich weiß die das waren helmut kohl aus
ist also richtiges kleines spießer
aquarium und ich das was ich hab das
versucht so auszusehen wie ein aquarium
zu okay das heißt du hast einen spieß
aquarium natürlich
tiefer gelegt quasi so ein oligarchen
aquarium hast du ja aber elegant dabei
also nicht so einen schlechten
geschmacks aquarium naja so richtig fast
zwei meter lang ok und 65 zentimeter
hoch 60 zentimeter tief ist also ein
schrank darunter natürlich nicht so ein
brauner wie bei helmut kohl sondern so
was auch aus alu
milchglasscheiben und der das
interessante ist eben beides zusammen
also das becken das glas das wasser da
drin und der schrank dass wir über eine
tonne
das hatte ich in meiner wohnung in köln
und nachdem das er aufgebaut war war ich
dann ganz stolz merkte aber so ein
bisschen dass sich der fußboden
veränderte ja also wenn man wenn man 52
ja mein sohn war damals klein wenn er
sein ball hinlegte dann rollte der in
die mitte des raumes und da wurde mir
mulmig natürlich auch zu luftlinie nur
ein meter fünfzig vom aquarium
geschlafen habe und dann habe ich dann
sehr schnell einen statiker angerufen
und er hat mir da noch irgendwas erzählt
von 25% tragwerks überschreitung und das
war jetzt auch eine schöne altbauwohnung
naja also auch alles ganz toll sich
holzdecke immer noch besser als 16 jahre
bau oder kann sich das ganze nicht mit
300 kilo pro quadratmeter belasten naja
und dann wusste unter das aquarium eine
riesige spanplatte ihr nicht werden ja
die habe ich dann auch so ein bisschen
mit alu überzogen es hat mich so ganz
hässlich aus der oligarchen mäßig ja
aber dann stand das quasi jetzt auch
noch aus so riesen podest weil die ist
ja klar je größer die auflagefläche umso
besser verteilt sich der druck und umso
geringer ist die die belastung
[Musik]
und was hast du da drin diesmal klar ist
wer schwimmt da nemo oder wir spielen ja
es ist tatsächlich ein süßwasseraquarium
na das unterscheidet mich auch von
oligarchen also ein wahrer aquarien
oligarch wir wissen
genau wir hatten haider oft den
spitznamen vladimir hört oder
dimitri
großartig hat und süßwasser ja das heißt
da schwimmt das war schon zwei schützen
fische drin
schützen fische können auf eine
entfernung von bis zu ein meter fünfzig
insekten von blättern trotzen ich habe
das mal gesehen in highspeed aufnahmen
bei wo 19.30 zdf terrex hallo in
highspeed wahnsinnig schön leise und es
gibt einen naturfotografen deutschen
heißt er den hab ich mal porträtiert
dass eine halbe ewigkeit her und der hat
fotos gemacht wo man dann wirklich so
millimeter für millimeter die spucke
daraus flugs isar bis das insekt
getroffen wird er hat aber für diese
aufnahmen ein jahr gebraucht weil dieser
schützen fisch bei ihm nie gerotzt
hin wahrscheinlich zu gut gefüttert und
irgendwann ist er aus dem becken
gesprungen und nachdem dein halben
todeskampf hinter sich hat um wieder
rein kommen und da meint ihr denn deuten
zu mir hätte jetzt begriffen dass das
leben ein kampf ist und dass man auch
für seine ernährung was tun muss und
dann hat er tatsächlich gespuckt ist das
gut also meine meine spucken wenn die
als die neuwagen haben die also die
ganze nacht gegen die alu verkleidung
gerotzt was also richtig krach gemacht
was doch er macht man das presley sich
fast dafür ein geräusch wird es klopft
so aber wenn das so
56 fische machen das ist schon passiert
sowieso ein getrommel ist unserem
regentropfen sind so
super ja das hast du die ganze nacht und
das ist der hier also das ist das haben
wir relativ schnell aufgehört haben
gesehen da kommt nix runter
und die sind aber unglaublich was also
wenn man im schlüssel die wohnung
aufschließen naja dann schießen die
gleiche an die dort alles die können
unterschiedliche menschen am schritt
erkennen doch die wissen dass sie vor
mir gefüttert werden aber von anderen
personen hier nicht nein nicht dein
ernst doch oder reagieren die relativ
wenig und auf denen er sie füttert
reagieren sie dann ganz stark ja das
können die die haben ganz ganz feine
ohren also die höheren alles ist
faszinierend
ist wirklich faszinierend das ist meine
bienen können ja die ersten beiden die
ich hatte ich hatte ursprünglich mal
zwei und die hießen und frank walter und
angela weil die haben beide so extrem
hängende mundwinkel und
jetzt habe ich aber eine etwas andere
art dahinter mundwinkel nicht ganz so
runter deswegen sind sie namenlos
geblieben olaf
muss von ihnen in der obersten liga
bleiben
das wird auch papst ist du schöner name
für fischfans für dich auf olaf ist sehr
sehr schön
olaf ich meine kinder haben so ein
kleines lamas und rosa lama so ein
pyjama und das nenne ich immer günther
das will ich im iran das passe sich so
ein lama mit namen günter ach das ist ja
herrlich also und was macht dieses
aquarium et richard also ich habe das
aquarium seit
13 jahren ich hab das gekauft von dem
vorschuss für wer bin ich nicht mehr weg
zum damaligen zeitpunkt war noch nicht
klar dass das buch sich gut verkaufen
würde das hier war der vor schluss zwar
ganz ordentlich aber jetzt auch nicht
vor and andere leute erfüllen sich damit
den traum und nimm kredit auf und kaufen
sich ein porsche oder so na ja und mein
branche ist halt dieses aquarium super
ein statussymbol quasi ja was gibt dir
das also ich erst mal ist dass china
viele tiere einfach unglaublich schön
das geht mir ja auch mit vögeln so und
mit fischen und natürlich gibt es auch
ganz ganz tolle säugetiere und meine
lieblingstiere sind meistens er so nicht
die tiere die andere schulden finden
also ich bin jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
hunde katzen kaninchen geht so aber ich
finde einfach so wirklich exotische
tiere seit ich kind bin also als
schönste säugetier ist ein ameisenbär
zum beispiel finde ich unglaublich schon
ernst jetzt ja finde ich ja so
faszinieren
und ja als bei vögeln natürlich
greifvögel klar oder so horn flügen und
finde ich unglaublich schön und dass es
geht mir genauso mit solchen fischen
also ich kann mir die auch nach vielen
vielen jahren noch angucken und es gibt
mir tatsächlich was und das
faszinierende an den tieren ist ja immer
dass das zweckmäßig keiten ohne zweck
sind das sind also in sich
funktionierende lebewesen die aber nicht
vom menschen geschaffen worden sind
sozusagen werte die nicht der mensch
geschaffen hat und da habe ich irgendwie
eine tiefe fast religiöses verhältnis zu
und er sowie natur an sich ja es gibt ja
leute die die sind unglaublich
fasziniert war von technik er auf das
neueste handy ist oder eine ganz tolle
kamera oder historische technik alter
autos alte kameras
und ich kann das schon irgendwie
nachvollziehen aber richtig fasziniert
mich vor allen dingen das was der mensch
nicht selbst geschaffen hat
und das ist also bei tieren dass diese
faszination bei mir ganz tief und groß
ich weiß nicht woher kommt ich hatte das
schon als kind
interessant ich habe das bei natur wenn
ich bis heute wenn ich wenn ich jemanden
dolomiten stehe und ich sehe zum
beispiel diese kennst du diese invasions
lagen wenn du wenn du weit oben auf dem
berg stehst und du kannst genau die
einzelnen luftschichten so sehen wo sie
ist genau wie wie sich das so
runterziehen wenn die kälte zum beispiel
dann
unten liegt dem tal du siehst aber auch
wenn es sich manchmal umgedrehten wenn
die kälte dann oben liegt und die wärme
und licht usw ist total fasziniert und
wie sich aguilera wie bei auf caspar
david friedrichs bild daran nebelmeer ja
wir haben bisher schon genannt hinten
sind 250 schattierungen von grau die in
das ist geborgen das ist der punkt genau
dann stapeln sich in den schlaf sei ja
genau kinder häufig die shades of two
mieten genau das ist wirklich schön wenn
sich dann im hintergrund so diese diese
bergketten stapeln und du weißt irgendwo
ganz weit weg ist österreich das ist das
ist wirklich das finde ich erhaben und
das hat dann so eine das ist mein sohn
biene maja moment was tun einfach so
einer wiese stehst und es hat eigentlich
gar kein 7 darum zu stehen aber jeweils
das energie diese daten sind gewinnt man
ja durch die dinge die keinen
praktischen sinn
das ist das was ich vorhin gesagt hab
zweckmäßigkeit ohne zweck na also
einfach einfach etwas was einen sinn in
sich trägt aber keinen praktischen sind
genau die zweckmäßigkeit ein ohne zweck
ist eigentlich inbegriff von kant aus
dem anderen kontext es hat darüber über
über das das schöne gesagt ihre kunst
ist zweckmäßigkeit ohne zweck ich habe
das ein bisschen entfremdet weil gerne
für natur gilt das noch viel mehr aber
für kunst auch nur also wenn du vor
seinem vor so einem großen bild stehst
weil du gerade caspar david friedrich
sagt ist kann man sich in der kunsthalle
in hamburg ansehen da wir glaube ich
schon mal darüber gesprochen dass ein so
unglaublicher moment wenn du dieses
weltberühmte bild du gehst auf dieses
auf dieses bild zu und sie ist nur
dieses bild
und und dass das ist im moment bemerkt
okay da hat jemand etwas ganz großes
geschaffen erst mal gar nicht danach
gefragt was ihm das eigentlich
unmittelbar bringt falls es von caspar
david friedrich ist ja
ja ich hab ich empfehle die lions in der
hamburger kunsthalle trotzdem weil es
also da gibt's nicht in wolfgang
beltracchi ja aber es ist mir nicht von
caspar david friedrich cerha stu und
rapid zu hause sagt mal ehrlich wie ich
habe keinen aber ich hätte gern ein ich
auch ich ging auch hier häufiger begegne
ich ja auch wir schätzen uns ja auch und
sich wieder der große wunder und der
kunstwelt fall des jahrhunderts musste
er wurde wahrscheinlich sagen die
kunstwelt ramallah jahrhundert also
vielleicht der beste kunstfälscher den
es je gab und
das bezeichnen da eines guten
kunstfälscher das ist herr nicht dass er
ein original
originalgetreu ab malt und das könnten
viele sondern dass er lauter max ernst
der erfunden hat die witwe von max
abends gesagt hat das sind die besten
bilder die man je gemalt heißt die
geschichte wie auch erzählt das ist so
gut ich habe ich es mal versucht also
mit mit mit wolfgang beltracchi
ernsthaft sozusagen über die den den
frevel einer kunstfälschung zu reden ist
fast unmöglich die hatten so einen
wunderschönen moment ich habe dann
gesagt ein beltracchi das kann man doch
nicht machen so ein kunstwerk ist doch
immer auch ein ergebnis der seiner
jeweiligen zeit und da ist der ganze
welt schmerz drin den der künstler da
fühlt und so weiter und die katastrophen
und dieser jeweilige zeit ja und die
großen krisen des jahrhunderts
trakt mich so mit großen augen an und
sagt ja ja das sagen sie alle
ich würde in einer aussage gut weil sie
so richtig ist dass ich gesagt hätte
hätte es unter 400 bilder gefälscht und
er hat gesagt hätte noch nie ein bild
gefällt mir genau während alles original
beltracchi ist das einzige was er
gefällt städte wäre die unterschrift als
auch noch besser bei mir in der sendung
hat er gesagt
das seien keine fälschungen er habe
lediglich das werk des künstlers achtung
ergänzt aber
aber eine neue strecke habe ich leider
deswegen nicht weil ich ihn mir nicht
leisten können das ist das lebenslicht
inzwischen sind die beltracchis richtig
teuer geworden ja das ist unfassbar der
liebermann von beltracchi kostet mehr
lieberman selbst
eines tages wird es vielleicht
tatsächlich so scheint genau ich weiß
auch bis heute nicht was aus diesen
großartigen max ernst die ich auch
wirklich für die besten max ernst
erhalten genau wie max ernst witte was
aus denen eigentlich geworden ist ich
wäre gerne erwerben ich glaube
irgendjemand partie und freut sich
darüber dass er sie hat ja es ist
interessant erinnerst du dich wie kommen
jetzt wirklich vom hölzchen aufs
stöckchen aber macht mal macht nichts
wir sind und podcast du hast dich an
arno funke
sagte er was der berühmte kaufhaus
erpresser dagobert naja dagobert maier
arno funke und der war nachdem er im
gefängnis gesessen hatte hat er eine
biografie veröffentlicht und war dann
auch bei uns in der sendung und ich fand
das damals also die geschichte fand ich
so kriminell wie sie ist und und ehrlich
gesagt sehr verwerflich und dachte man
das macht man so nicht und weißt du was
mich aber am meisten angerührt hat war
dass dieser mann eigentlich ein anderes
ganz tolles talent hatte das ist ein
ganz wunderbarer grafiker ein toller
zeichner und ich habe im original arno
funke zu hause weil ich das weiß ich
dass ich habe ihn darum gebeten und habe
hat mir dann irgendetwas skizziert und
so weiter runter ja und ich habe den zu
hause und freue mich dass ich den habe
und dachte oh mein gott was ist das
eigentlich für ein für ein schicksal und
für eine für eine unglückselige
lebensgeschichte dass jemand der
eigentlich ein richtiges talent hat dann
irgendwann komplett falsch abbiegt und
an diesen mist macht wie die selecta
starter presse gesagt dass beltracchi
nicht passiert werden der lavadom
italien gemacht beltracchi auch ganz
kurz vor vor klassen
mehrere
erstaunlich hoch bestraft worden er hat
sich natürlich sehr mächtige feinde
gemacht ja und jetzt fällt mir grad
wieder ein blick in die geschichte
kennst du die geschichte dahinter wie
sie in weich gekocht haben die der
mittlerweile stimmt zu die geschichte
verläuft wolfgang beltracchi ist ein
sehr
ausgekochtes schlitzohr aber er hat eine
große schwäche und das ist seine frau ja
das weiß ich genau der liebt seine frau
abgöttisch und über alles und sie ihn
auch sie ihn auch genau so eine ganz
große liebe und dass die haben ihn dann
in untersuchungshaft haben sie so
gemacht dass sie ihn so platziert haben
dass er wenige meter von seiner frau weg
war
quasi an der quer bahnhof und das wusste
er und sie wusste es auch das hat ihn
fertig gemacht aber wir haben sich
briefe geschrieben wie genau ich weiß
nicht wie viele am tag also ich glaube
es gibt kaum eine frau die so viele
liebesbriefe in ihrem leben krieg wie
backt er an seine frau an einem tag
geschrieben und ja genau und damit haben
sie ihn weich gekocht haben gesagt was
oft eine frage die nur so viel alles was
ich habe ist nicht weit weg und du
kannst sie wieder sehen wenn nun
geständnis abgelegt ja aber er hat halo
die gestanden ja man ihm nachweisen sein
musste genau also ich hatte ihn zum
beispiel gefragt ob er mir einen morandi
malen kann da ist mein lieblings maler
giorgio morandi
und dann hat er gesagt
schwer obwohl da hätte schon ein paar
mal gemacht ich sage was wo hängen die
denn ja kann ich dir jetzt so nicht
sagen
also wenn es stimmt hängen darf auch
einige hundert beltracchis in den museen
dieser welt wäre aber weißt du das ist
ein bisschen wie mit einer gefälschten
rolex herum das jetzt hier nicht nicht
sozusagen so zu tun als wäre es
erstrebenswert eine kunstfälschung zu
besitzen ich finde ja wenn leute kommen
und sagen guckt die rolex ja die sie zu
täuschend echt aus ist eine perfekte uhr
das sieht kein mensch da wirklich immer
ja mag ja sein aber du weißt es doch du
weißt doch dass das ding nicht echt ist
gilt ja für alle anderen uhren auch er
ist völlig egal was du da fällt aber
oder auch für taschen oder für schuhe
und so weiter du weißt es doch worum
geht es eigentlich geht ja aber ich
denke man kann ja darum geht dass es von
außen dafür gehalten wird genau das
erzählt hat auch ein bisschen was über
dich selbst nie hat morandi warum sein
lieblingskünstler ja also ich habe das
tatsächlich gemeinsam entdeckt mit
meinem vater und zwar auf der west kunz
1980 war ich 15 jahre älter und in dem
alter habe ich mich enorm für kunst
interessiert habe auch selber so zeichen
lehrgänge und sowas gemacht und
unglaublich viel gezeichnete derzeit und
morandi ist auf den ersten blick
überhaupt nicht spektakulär das sind
kleine bilder meistens so 50 60
zentimeter in der diagonalen als
wirklich klein
und der hat sein leben lang in bologna
gesessen und hat flaschen und schachtel
gemalt so und dann hat er diese flaschen
und schachteln aber nicht versucht so
fotorealistisch zu malen nach sowie
shutter oder so die stillleben maler ist
18 jahrhunderts sondern er hat die
angemalt also er hat die quasi ihrer
identität beraubt okay man also eine
schachtel zieht dann aus sowieso weiß
grau oder braun bemalt wie so ein tolles
stück kuchen oder so und dann hat er
zeit seines lebens quasi versucht das
optimale bild zu malen das gleiche gibt
es ja von sc sand genauer der diesem
ensemble ja hunderte von malen immer
wieder und immer wieder gemalt hat und
so ähnlich kann man das auch vergleichen
ist auch für normal technik ein bisschen
ähnlich wie sun und dann hat er immer
wieder und immer wieder so stillleben
arrangiert aus flaschen und schachteln
und man kann diesen bildern eigentlich
überhaupt nicht erkennen wie alt sind
die gegenstände dann ist das gemalt
lassen dadurch entsteht zeitlosigkeit
also doppelt zeitlosigkeit die
maltechnik dass das könnte 100 jahre
spielraum sein das könnte aus der zeit
aus der zeit sein dann hast du diese
gegenstände die du nicht genau erkennen
kannst ihre identität verloren haben und
dadurch entsteht so ein ganz spezieller
zauber auf diesen bildern vor einigen im
spätwerk also die das frühwerk das ist
ja dunkel
und flächen fast ein bisschen depressiv
aber so die die späten sachen wir ihn
jetzt 50er 60er jahre ich glaube dass 64
gestorben die haben einen unglaublichen
sauber also das ist finde ich die sehe
dann werde ich so ganz ganz kommt mal
ganz zu sich und ganz runter und die
schatten sind so gemalt dass man nicht
erkennen kann ist dass der schatten des
einen oder des anderen also man
verschwimmt so ein bisschen mit dem bild
und also das ist wirklich ein großer
künstler und der ist tatsächlich erst so
richtig berühmt geworden so etwa in der
zeit als mein vater und ich und den so
für uns entdeckt haben also da wurde der
systematisch gesammelt und wurde auch in
kurzer zeit sehr teuer
wir hatten natürlich beide nicht
ausreichend geld um uns hier in manila
hier vorher gallerani es heute richtig
teuer und was kostet der heute so
ziemlich klassisch es gibt ja ich weiß
es nicht genau aber einige
hunderttausend wird er sich hat okay
aber naja vielleicht sogar ein großes
übel sich hat noch mehr ich mache mich
fotografie wie du weißt ich liebe
fotografie aber das ist er eigentlich so
ein ausweichmanöver immer gewesen weil
ich überhaupt nicht zeichnen und malen
kann ich kann das gar nicht mein bruder
ist ein sehr begabter zeichner und so
weiter in meiner familie gibt sie ihren
und man kann ja nicht verletzen können
und daher komponieren ist ein sehr
großes wort ein sehr großes wort für das
was ich da gemacht habe früher aber ich
habe mich mit musik immer viel
beschäftigt aber kunst ich kann es nicht
aber ich liebe es und ich finde es gibt
ich habe zum beispiel meinen
lieblingskünstler und überhaupt meine
lieblings epoche so klassische moderne
und da im speziellen so ein paar
österreicher ja wenn du albin egger
lienz zum beispiel das ist ein mann mit
einer faszinierenden geschichte der
glaubt er war ein adoptivkind in den
mann ende neunzehnten jahrhundert in
osttirol aufgewachsen in lienz und
ist einer der sich dann so
durchgeschlagen hat ja das kann man sich
vorstellen ich meine damals ein
uneheliches kind warst dann war das
natürlich kein spaß speziell in dieser
sehr konservativen bäuerlichen welt in
der er aufgewachsen ist und dass mein
absoluter lieblingsmaler von dem gibt es
ein paar sachen und weil du gerade sagt
ist immer wieder das gleiche motiv
wiederholt und variiert und versucht
besser zu machen das hast du bei dem
auch da gibt es ein paar motive die vor
allen dingen bezugnehmend auf den ersten
weltkrieg der totentanz zb ganz ganz
berühmte das motiv und dann gibt es
andere motive die ich zum beispiel so
liebe aus dieser bäuerlichen welt und er
hat am anfang sehr gegenständlich gemalt
und dann immer abstrakter und hat dann
irgendwann gesagt ich male keine keine
keine bauern sondern ich male formel du
siehst doch nie so ein richtiges gesicht
du ahnst das gesicht das ist alles so
kantig und uns sehr und sehr groß und so
weiter die hände spielen eine große
rolle und ich bin ja oft in den
dolomiten unterwegs also auf einsamen
bergbauernhöfe und fotografiere manchmal
so diese letzten bergbauern die es da
gibt und fotografiere dann auch immer
die hände ist und schwarz weiß um diese
hände sind exakt so wie albin
egger-lienz sie gemalt hat und das finde
ich so faszinierend weil du siehst wie
wichtig diese hände ja dieses werkzeug
für für diese menschen natürlich ist sie
haben deswegen sehen sie entsprechend
ausgeprägt
du hast zb auch frauen alte hier mal
eine alte bäuerin fotografiert von 87
jahren die wie so eine junge 30 jährige
auf dem feld darum tote und untreue
machte ja wie man das bei uns nennt und
die hatte ich habe die hände von der
fotografierten solche händlers und nicht
gesehen die waren doppelt so groß wie
meine so so richtig knochige starke
unglaubliche hände die sich im laufe
dieses lebens halt so ausgebildet haben
und das ist das was mich an egger lienz
war so fasziniert und an diese erdigen
schönen farben und das interessante war
und deswegen
erzähle ich manchmal auch jüngeren
leuten davon wenn du was ich zum
beispiel mein sohn der es im bereich
informatik und weiter unterwegs und mit
mit kunst haben dies manchmal nicht so
und ich sollte ihn beschäftige mit dich
mal damit und wenn es dich erwischt dann
weißt du es auch ich weiß ich hab ich
habe mich für kunst überhaupt nicht
interessiert und dann irgendwann in der
vierten klasse war 19 jahre alt brachte
unser
kunstlehrer ein buch mit über albin
egger lienz und habe ich das erste mal
diese bilder gesehen und war von der
ersten sekunde an fasziniert und diese
faszination hat hält bis heute an ich
hab nichts davon verloren
weil ich verstanden habe instinktiv wir
werden keine ahnung von kunst ja aber
ich habe instinktiv verstanden das ist
ganz groß was du da gerade siehst und so
ging es mir später noch mal dann bei
alfons walde ich weiß nicht ob du den
kennst das ein kitzbüheler künstler
ähnliche zeit und die haben beide sender
in der spätphase die ganz großen sachen
gemacht sondern 1920 er jahren gibt es
ganz ganz tolle dinge und es ist so
faszinierend weil die bilder von alfons
walde die die hängen glaube ich viel den
sehr teuren chalets in kitzbühel rum da
gibt es auch ein tolles alfons walde
museum und was du da siehst ist von der
so ein lebenslustiger unterinntal und
albin egger lienz ist er so die
abteilung depressive osttiroler ja das
ist also das ding aber beide kinder
ihrer zeit und einer gründlichen leben
jahrmarkt jaja der der walde beide sehr
bäuerliches leben über genau aber wenn
du die bilder mal vergleicht kann man
sofort googeln albin egger lienz und
dann schaust du dir mal alfons walde
das ist von der technik ganz ganz
ähnlich auch sehr pastors und so weiter
teilweise gespachtelt gibt doch in
diesen bildern von alfons walde gibt es
immer wenn er diese bauernhöfe gemalt
hat geht es meistens so an der rote
geranien im bild du siehst die hatte
einfach so die also die rote farbe
einfach so von der tube aus so direkt
vor eingedrückt in dieses bild ist
wirklich faszinierend und ganz plastisch
dadurch ja fast dreidimensional und
egger ist ganz anders das ist viel
zurückhaltender und und flächiger gemalt
und so weiter was spannend aber
der kunst ganz grundsätzlich halte ich
meine was ist die faszination von kunst
für menschen was warum warum erzielen
kunstwerke jetzt jenseits von
spekulation ich glaube nicht dass es da
immer nur um spekulation geht solche
wahnsinns preise abverlangt ich würde
den kunstmarkt den duellen alles ganz
sauber der trainer davon der frage was
ist ein gutes kunstwerk oder was macht
kunst mit menschen ich unterrichte
juni in berlin also einer
musikhochschule hanns eisler dort
unterricht richtig angeben der
komponisten das heißt eingehen die sind
ja schon komponisten sonst hätten sie
die aufnahmeprüfung gar nicht geschaffen
das schaffen dann vielleicht fünf sechs
unter 1000
und mit dem beschäftige ich mich ja sehr
viel mit ästhetik und
das ist ja ein thema was wir da auch
immer versuchen in all seinen aspekten
aufzulösen und dann muss man einfach mal
kunz grundsätzlich sagen also der markt
ist immer etwas ganz ganz anderes als
die frage was ist ein ästhetischer fährt
und ich weiß was macht ein kunstwerk zu
einem guten kunstwerk ich meine wie
viele dinge haben riesigen erfolg an
märkten gehabt und war nicht besonders
hochwertig und wie viele großartige
künstler die wir heute kennen waren zu
ihrer zeit völlig missachtet nicht
geschätzt sind nicht wahrgenommen worden
diese riesen preise einem kunstmarkt
sind keine spekulations preise also es
gibt keine korrelation zwischen preisen
die für künstler ausgegeben werden und
dem können oder in der ästhetik dieser
bilder
dass man könnte vielleicht sagen dass
der wahrscheinlich teuerste deutsche
künstler tatsächlich also ein überragend
guter mann erst gerhard richter ja eine
ganz andere liga als emmendorf oder oder
pink oder so also leute in deren umfeld
er berühmt geworden ist sie aber auch
noch erstaunlicher preise dafür dass sie
vielleicht nicht so ganz große künstler
waren erzielt haben oder immer noch
erzielen und da kann es war einfach sein
der ja der der spekulations anteil bei
kunst ist es ähnlich hoch und die leute
die das geld haben für künstler zehn
millionen 20 millionen 50 millionen zu
bezahlen sind nur in sehr seltenen
fällen kunstkenner
machen ja gar nicht selber die haben
ihre agentin die dass für sie die aktien
anlegen und die wiederum begriffe sich
auf die expertise von leuten die etwas
von kunst verstehen oder vom kunstmarkt
verstehen
zurückrufen also im grunde genommen ist
das ein
völlig merkwürdige welt man kann
wirklich sagen der kunstmarkt ist sicher
das zweitälteste gewerbe der welt
und ich finde es ist eine beste was ich
daran so verwerflich finde ich finde es
verwerflich wenn man dann diese viele
kohle dafür einsetzt um wirklich nur
damit zu spekulieren und am ende führt
dazu dass du zum beispiel in bestimmten
bereichen nicht mal lange reportage
darüber gelesen in südostasien gibt es
ganze magazine lagerhallen bestens
bewacht perfekt klimatisiert wo einfach
nur von tageslicht selbstverständlicher
böses uv-licht ja bestens abgeschirmt
unfassbar teure kunst hängt reine
spekulation und das finde ich ehrlich
gesagt wirklich komplett daneben weil es
dann eben nur arbeits gebe es gebe
keinerlei rechtliche handhabe sondern
also sozusagen es gibt kein anrecht der
öffentlichkeit die seerosen von van gogh
zu sehen ja aber irgend einem
japanischen tresor oder sony genau und
das ist aber ehrlich gesagt das ist das
finde ich schlimm das ist total daneben
das ist ich finde ein großes kunstwerk
das war iris war das schwertlilien jetzt
wieder ein schwert gegen das war mal so
verlängere zeit das teuerste bild
da kann man heute jérôme sans moi ja
genau wie schwer schwertlilien es ist
und so ein bild fertig und schon
damaligen zeitpunkt überhaupt nicht
kannte obwohl ich ja sowieso von
kochbücher zu hause hat
die sonnenblume auch unsere das aber ich
denke da hat wolfgang beltracchi ganze
arbeit geleistet du hast ein monet zu
hause dann einen beltracchi monnet ja
ich habe
die frage ist ja ich hatte schönheiten
und und sozusagen was bedeutet menschen
schönheit philosophisch betrachtet ich
meine wenn man besuch als ich das erste
mal in kontakt kam mit
altgriechisch und auch mit latein usw
das zieht sich ja durch die gesamte
antike sozusagen dieses streben nach
schönheit und die der der der versuch
sozusagen etwas zu sein irgendwie
auszusehen etwas zu kreieren was was
ultimativ schön ist woher kommt das
also wahrscheinlich reiht sich das ein
in das bedürfnis des menschen nach etwas
was größer ist als er selbst
was ja auch ursprünglich für die
religion entscheidend war also gott
sollte das idealisierte sein das größer
ist als man selber und hätten über
schönheits sollte dann ist irgendwas
gleichen hat also die hoffnung etwas zu
finden was das normale menschliche
übersteigt
ich glaube dass das ist es ist genauso
wie das ideal des guten kein mensch
erfüllt das ideal des guten sondern man
kann nur versuchen sich dem ein wenig zu
nähern
oder das ideal unbegrenzte tapferkeit
das waren hier alles ideale der
täglichen kultur und in diesem gleichen
kontext fällt ja auch das ideal der
schönheit
und dann kommt ja nicht bei der bei der
schönheit die implizite tragische
dimension dazu dass das dass schönheit
eben der inbegriff von vergänglichkeit
ist ganz großen unterschied zu
werten oder so wer also nicht sozusagen
naturgemäß altert
also ich finde ich glaube dass es so die
die sehnsucht nach dem unbedingten und
das wissen um die tragik ich glaube das
ist immer immer im schulden mit drin das
wissen um die tragik ja das wissen um
die tragik der vergänglichkeit von
schönheit
ich meine das ist ja auch mit schönheit
so eine sache wir machen ja im
augenblick sind leben ja im zeitalter
der technischen reproduzierbarkeit von
schönheit natürlich schönheitschirurgie
und schönheits kosmetik wie man damals
ja eine bestimmte gesellschaftlich
akzeptierte schönheit erzeugen und die
kann man ja auch immer wieder neue und
neu erzeugen dann wenn man früh genug
damit anfängt dann kann man das relativ
lange halten man wird aber nie eine
echte schönheit damit erzeugen können
also ich denke diejenigen menschen die
man als wirklich schön empfindet sind
häufig menschen die völlig ungeachtet
irgendwelche eingriffe auch dann schön
sind wenn sie alt aussehen
und ich glaube das ist eine andere
andere vorstellungen von schönheit also
man kann auch sagen manche menschen
werden ja überhaupt erst im alter schön
also gibt es ein schöneres gesicht eines
alten mannes als der alte samuel beckett
zum beispiel drei seines lebens bei
überhaupt kein attraktiver mann war aber
gar nicht aber unglaublich war gut außer
im alltag der charles schumann
von der berühmte barbesitzer aus münchen
ich kenne ihn nicht wirkte nie getroffen
aber der erwartete der wurde dann im
reiferen alter öl plötzlich als model
war der sehr gefragt er allein alter
unfassbar gut ausgesehen hat aber das
ding ist doch heute wir sind doch in
einer zeit in der im grunde keiner mehr
das altern akzeptiert dazu sind wir doch
alle wollen alt werden aber keiner will
alt aussehen
ja weil mir ist das jetzt nicht ganz so
schlimm weil ich ein beruf anhänge wo
man erst angst genommen wird wenn man
anfängt ein bisschen leid auszusehen
also ein philosoph der keine grauen
haare hat es kein philosoph hast du
nicht das gefühl also ich glaube du hast
speziell auch instagram hast du mal so
eine rassismus maschine genannt
ich fand das damals ihren begriff auch
in harten begriff aber
am ende zeigt dass ohne jetzt werten zu
sein einfach nur so zu sagen wo das
schönheitsideal hingegen wie wir uns
eigentlich selber gerne hätten und du
hast du aber diesmal auf der anderen
seite ist es ja so ich meine wenn
irgendwann jeder getuntes mit den zauber
mitteln der schönheitsindustrie dann
verliert natürlich diese art von
schönheit ihren wert dass der punkt ja
also ich kann mich erinnern als damals
die diskussion war ende der neunziger
jahre
ob man irgendwann mal seine kinder die
sein kann da gab es einen belgischen
arzt bei dem man sich die augenfarbe
aussuchen konnte
also der hingegangen ist und der die die
spermien und befruchteten heißt alles
schon und so untersuchen konnte dass er
quasi die blauäugigen daraus filtern
konnte deswegen nicht so schwer ist weil
die augenfarbe mologen ist also auf
einem einzigen geben die glauben farmer
intelligenz liegt nicht auf einem
einzigen die den gästen kinder kann man
sich nicht aussuchen was kein mensch
weiß bis heute so richtig was
intelligenz ist also das funktioniert so
nicht aber bei der augenfarbe
funktioniert dass ich meine michelle
kommen her reitet er geheißen und da gab
es den richtigen tourismus dahin um das
zu machen und ich habe gedacht da wenn
das alle machen dann gibt es irgendwann
nur noch blauäugige kinder ja und dann
werden natürlich die braunen augen
unglaublich an wert gewinnen das macht
ja weil etwas dutzendfach und überall zu
haben ist das behält nie dauerhaft ein
wert sondern große große werte wie eben
auch der wert der schönheit sind an die
seltenheit gebunden und in einer
gesellschaft in der jeder auf die genau
gleiche art und weise die jugend ist und
alle gleich aussehen verliert die dieses
schönheitsideal rasant an wert und das
ist war immer da wenn du wenn du jeden
tag kaviar ist ist irgendwann das
butterbrot sentation gehe ich schon aus
also ich glaube jeden tag habe ja ich
habe es noch nicht ausprobiert wird
wahrscheinlich vater werden als jeden
tag nudeln ja und als jeden tag ein
gutes butterbrot genau so ist es wer war
das aber es ist trotzdem ich meine wir
wissen dass alles theoretisch aber ich
habe trotzdem das gefühl dass es
mittlerweile etwas geworden also
wirklich so nebenbei du gehst ja auch
gar nicht mehr zum gruß zum zum zum
hautarzt oder so sondern glücklich wie
ich weiß es gibt von von ärzten
hno-ärzten du kannst du mal eben du
lässt dir kurz die nase untersuchen und
nebenbei boom einmal botox in die stirn
und zwar mit der größten
selbstverständlichkeit und der arzt
selber übrigens auch
und sagte dass sie ihre zornesfalte und
so das ist sodann und dann kommst du ins
grübeln und erwarte mal wieder lösen
sind die dahinter liegt besteht ja darin
dass das irgendwann so norm ist genau
das die dum auffallen die nicht
mitmachen
und dann tritt der effekt ein dass auch
die sagen ich würde das niemals worten
dann wenn sie irgendwann die einzigen
sind in ihrem bekanntenkreis die alt
aussehen sich dann doch überlegen ob wir
das machen
und das ist eine gefahr die tatsächlich
passieren kann also die frage ist ob die
welle vorher kippt ja oder gebrochen
wird dass man dass man sagt naja ok das
daran kann man die nullerjahre die
einsame und die zwei jahre irgendwie
erkennen dass er die zeit als irgendwie
alle frauen schlauchbootlippen hatten ja
weil das vielleicht zwanzig jahre später
total out ist oder aber es war die
einstiegs zeit ja in dem es tatsächlich
noch frauen ohne schlauchbootlippen ab
dass es sehr schwer zu sagen welche
richtung es geht also ich finde nichts
wissen schwer zu sagen ist
er hat das gefühl der zug ist längst
unterwegs
kulturpessimist
dass kultur dialektisch ist das
sozusagen ja jede welle ihre
gegenbewegung
ja ich mache das aber jetzt gar nicht
wertend sondern ich glaube einfach nur
dass war eigentlich auch die die absicht
hinter meiner frage immer zu unter dich
von diesem wissen zu wollen wie sich
schlicht und ergreifend schönheitsideale
ändern weißt du wenn irgendwann
sozusagen common sense ist dass alle
frauen etwas wie soll man sagen kuss
freudige rippen haben dann ist das eben
so
das meine ich damit hat auch dass ich an
meine eben dass es irgendwann an wert
verliert wenn es jeder hat weil ich
meine dass das ideal der schönheit an
die bedingung der seltenheit gebunden
ist und
dass ich mir das anders nicht vorstellen
kann sonst ist meine theorie falsch da
als ich am anfang gesagt er mit den
griechen das hat man sich sozusagen
ideale gemacht hat die in der realität
fast nie vorkam und die deswegen
besonders wertvoll war und wenn wir
jetzt also schönheit im zeitalter ihrer
technischen reproduzierbarkeit haben
dann stellt sich eben die frage ob
dieses schönheitsideal sich nicht stark
verändern
und zwar am besten in so eine richtung
verändert die man technisch nicht her
stärker
naja das original gesicht ich meine das
nicht irre auf der einen seite sehen die
menschen ja dadurch mehr und mehr
geklont aus auf der anderen seite ist
eine der wichtigsten werte der jüngeren
generation authentizität das ist meint
dass man sich meist total dafür hafte
dateien reiter ja es ist ist das
manipulierte gesicht gerade nicht
authentisch ist auch die mimik kann
nicht mehr richtig authentisch rein weil
die angespannt die authentische mimik
nicht mehr zulässt und auf der anderen
seite ist diese forderung authentisch zu
sein so hoch wie noch nie in der
geschichte der menschheit
wie passt das zusammen und das ist das
interessante die gesellschaften bestehen
immer aus widersprüchen die nicht
zusammenpasst ja es gibt es gibt noch
einen anderen gedanken dazu das ist das
was die frage die ich mir stelle ist
richard das hast du ja zum beispiel auch
in der mode ja wenn wenn irgendetwas
passiert wenn jetzt zum beispiel im
moment wieder schlaghosen und
weiterkommen dann kannst du die uhr
danach stellen wann sämtliche deutsche
innenstädte wieder von starken besiegelt
werden ja das geht ganz schnell
und das interessante daran ist doch
eigentlich der gedanke warum macht man
das man macht es um sich von den anderen
abzuheben und dem bemühen möglichst
anders auszusehen sehen sie dann alle
wieder irgendwann gleich aus genauso ist
dass alle alle wollen das gleiche anders
sein als die angriffe
es war und das funktioniert halt nicht
weil in diesem bemühen ja anders zu sein
sich abzuheben gefälligst vom ganzen
großen rest der keine ahnung hat und
kann modebewusst sagt sehen die dann
irgendwann wirklich alle gleich aus aber
der sind mehr mode war ganz ehrlich
gesagt noch nie nur sich abzuheben wenn
das der sinn gewesen wären dann würden
die leute als mode das tragen was am
schrägsten ist so jetzt gibt es so ein
paar viertel wie berlin mitte und so
darf man das gefühl da ist das so aber
in jeder ganz normalen deutschen stadt
und kleinstadt und jedem dorf ist das
überhaupt nicht so sondern der der sinn
der mode besteht ja darin etwas
mitzumachen was alle machen um dabei zu
sein und innerhalb des dabei zu sein es
sich um eine nuance zu unterscheiden das
ist eigentlich wie mode funktioniert
seit das mode gibt
es ist wie besteht immer aus den beiden
polen ja das des mitmachens dessen was
die anderen machen und es sich
unterscheiden
als erstes steht doch dass man wird
durch die mode zeigt dass man
mitbekommen hat was die mode ist das ist
ja auch ganz ganz wichtig dass man nicht
noch die sachen von vor ein paar jahren
trägt oder dass man nicht kapiert hat
dass das und das auto ist und so es war
und mich faszinieren immer die leute
dahinter ne jemand wie jil sander zum
beispiel fasziniert mich total
jemand wie coco chanel wirklich mal mit
der geschichte von coco chanel
beschäftigst oder auch von karl
lagerfeld
coco chanel die dann irgendwann einfach
anfing sozusagen bequeme klamotten zu
machen korsagen weg es heißt die hat
verstanden oder vorweggenommen ein
lebensgefühl nicht nur einer generation
von 250 generationen von frauen
eine eine frau die die ich glaube ich
glaube die waffen dürfen der
klosterschule ist dort auch immer
ausgelacht worden usw mies behandelt
worden weil sie immer so ihr eigenes
ding macht und ihrer eigenen welt
unterwegs war dann angefangen zu nehmen
und so weiter und hat dann immer weiter
konsequent ihren weg gesucht in dieser
welt glaube mit hüten dann an gefangenen
fingen pariser frauen an dieser hütte
plötzlich gut zu finden und dann so
frauen und was die klamotte angeht also
die frauenmode systematisch so entstaubt
lässiger gemacht und eigentlich so die
frage ist ja immer die nach huhn und ei
was war da zuerst war das bedürfnis der
frauen endlich anders auszusehen und
sich anders zu kleiden oder hat sie
dieses bedürfnis erst geweckt dass sich
das große glück hätte sicherlich eine
große rolle dass sie das geweckt hat
wenn du das so erzählt es gab ja damals
auch mit hilfe der mode noch was frei zu
kämpfen oder neues frauenbild überhaupt
so genau
als ich aus gewissen zwängen zu lösen
das gibt es ja heute bei uns alles nicht
mehr also diese mode die ja auch mal so
eine emanzipatorische funktion hatte
oder gesellschaftliche befreiungs
funktionen das alles muss ja heute
gepflegt werden
also was will man denn die und die mode
dennoch irgendwie befreien also das ist
ja man kann das noch versuchen auf fotos
zu inszenieren oder so aber wir leben ja
nun leider in diesen sachen in seiner
spät kultur irgendwo na also in eine
kleine kultur die keine tabus mehr zu
brechen hat und auch keinen keinen
richtigen aufbruch mehr in irgendetwas
neues oder anderes hinbekommen kann
jedenfalls auf dieser ebene nicht mehr
das stimmt dann der große schlachten
geschlagen sind die großen kulturellen
schlachten und ja gut werden jetzt die
große kulturelle schlacht zu schlagen
irgendwie hinzu kommen in eine
nachhaltige gesellschaft nur ist das für
die mode bislang nicht so wahnsinnig
aufregend das gibt es natürlich alles na
also nachhaltig hergestellte textilien
und in denen man das ansieht oder dem
man das nicht ansieht usw
aber das führt ja nicht so zu einer art
gesellschaftlicher emanzipation oder so
das kann ich irgendwie nicht wirklich
erkennen das ist an einem spaten segment
unter 100 anderen da geht kein aufbruch
von aus
richard eine sehr heitere folge finde
ich speziell am anfang wir sind über das
aquarium zur großen kunst zu beltracchi
zu büchern so schön als idealen gekommen
ich finde das kann man irgendwo unter so
einer verträumten per mail sondern
verträumten liegestuhl irgendwo nicht
mal ganz gut weg hören das hat großen
spaß gemacht haben
bis bald
[Musik]
eine produktion von m 52 und popstars
der im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]